I've zeroed out that if the United
States does not take but does not seek
great innovations in space it will be
second in space with sure as night
follows day there's no country more
innovative an inventive than the United
States so it's just important to use
that attribute that's that's the ace
card okay I mean I do think it's it's
absolutely fundamental to achieve full
reusability in access to space this is
this is the holy grail of space at the
point at which you have full reusability
for openal rockets then you have a
profound advantage over anyone else it's
profound or shared multi-use planes that
can be flown over and over again like
normal and all your adversary's had
single-use planes that would be no
contest it's the same thing in space
okay yeah this is extremely fundamental
so just like an aircraft you the the
rocket must be rapidly and completely
reusable and then you need lots of them
the massive thing that can be done is to
make sure your incentive structure is
such that innovation is rewarded and
lack of innovation is punished
there gotta be a characteristic so if
somebody is innovating and doing making
good progress then they should be
promoted sooner and if somebody is
completely failing to innovate not every
role requires innovation but if they're
in a role where innovation is should be
happening and it's not happening then
they should either not be promoted or
exited and let me tell you you'll get
remote you could view it you'll get
innovation real fast when trying
different things you got to have some
acceptance of failure as you're learning
to earlier failure must be an option if
failure is not an option it's gonna
result in extremely conservative choices
and you may not get something even worse
than lack of innovation things may go
backwards
well what I mean by the machine that
pulls the machine is that the the
production but designing the production
system of a new product is I think at
least an order of magnitude or two
magnitude hotter than designing the
initial prototype yeah for sure we were
doing push in the beginning because
people said there was no one telling us
that they wanted an electric car so it
was not it was not out of like you know
it was like less people coming up to me
saying hey I really want electric car
and I heard that zero times
Sabir like it's like man we're gonna
make him let your car and show that
these things can be good
and then people want them you know it's
like because like Henry Ford said like
the you know we're so about the Model T
is like if you ask the public what they
wanted that say a faster horse it's like
when when it's erratically a new product
people don't know that they want it
because it's just not in there in the
inner scope probably the most
transformative most fundamentally
transformative will be AI it's
essentially an information theory and
physical theory if you want understand
the nature of the universe and how these
have an very good predictive power
physics and computer science okay but
and I think that you could actually do
point-to-point on earth with you know to
go in long distances and be much better
than aircraft because I mean basically
just think of like ICBM - the nuke
Aadland you know so it's just sort of in
the option package just yeah
uncheck nuke and then add landing system
and and that's definitely gonna get you
wherever you want to go spread the
fastest I think things like things of
air I'm definitely gonna go into kind of
autonomous Oh
locally autonomous drone warfare it's
where it's at where the future will be
I'm just saying it was not I want the
future to be this it's just this is what
the future will be okay yes autonomous
drone warfare yeah well actually at
Tesla we just open sourced our patents
some years ago so anyone can use our
patents so we really have not been tried
to protect intellectual property in that
sense we've tried to actually smooth the
path because the the overarching goal of
Tesla is to accelerate the advent of
sustainable energy and so if we created
a patent portfolio that discouraged
other companies from making electric
cars that would be inconsistent with our
mission so we open sourced all the
patents
yeah in order to help the other and
anyone else who wants to make an
electric car so I guess that's the
opposite of protecting the IP now the
real way I think you you actually
achieve intellectual property protection
right is by innovating fast enough if
your rate of innovation is high then you
don't need to worry about protecting the
IP because other companies will be
copying something that you did years ago
and that's fine you know just make sure
your your rate of innovation is fast
speed is really the speed of innovation
is what is what matters the thing that
will be that will feel pretty strange is
that the Chinese economy is going to be
probably at least twice as big as the US
economy maybe three times but at least
twice so the notice here is a GDP per
capita so less than the US but since
they have about four or five times the
population then it would only require
getting to a GDP per capita of half the
United States for their economy to be
twice the size of ours and as I'm sure
people in this room know the foundation
of war is economics therefore in order
for us to be competitive on military
level the innovation has to overcome a
gigantic gap in economic output okay so
in the absence of radical innovation the
US will be militarily second okay I
think we're going to make starfleet
happen
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so so we're like our real big spaceships
that can go far places it's like just
try to make Starfleet happen as as soon
as humanly possible and definitely virus
it while we're still alive yeah so I'm
not sure about wolf drive but we can
other stuff I think can be done yeah
help wolf drive and teleportation
probably not but big spaceships I can go
far places definitely that could be done
[Music]